ma présentation s'articulera autour d'un
constat général d'une appréciation des
résultats obtenus par les exploitants et
dans les domaines différents domaines
d'activité puis du rappel de quelques
faits marquants
compte tenu du contexte si vous le
permettez monsieur le président monsieur
le vice président je terminerai mon
intervention par quelques éléments liés
à la gestion de la situation pandémique
que vides 19
tout d'abord un constat général l'asn
estime que le niveau de sûreté et de
radioprotection dans les installations
et les activités nucléaires a été
acceptable en 2019 avec des points
positifs que je soulignerai mais aussi
des points qui nécessite des
améliorations plusieurs points positifs
peuvent appuyer ce constat général
tout d'abord dans le domaine nucléaire
aucun incident majeur n'est affecté les
installations en service et aucun rejet
significatifs dans l'environnement n'a
été constatée en 2010 9 l'année 2019 a
été marquée par une plus grande prise de
conscience par les exploitants
nucléaires des défis auxquels ils sont
confrontés collectivement notamment en
termes de renforcement des compétences
et de la qualité des réalisations
cette prise de conscience s'est appuyé
sur les positions répétées de l'asn mais
aussi sur les conclusions du rapport
falls et sur les réflexions collectives
engagé par la filière au sein du gie
feng les mesures engagées par les
exploitants suite à la découverte de
fraudes ont permis de progresser
les analyses des exploitants et les
investigations menées par l'asn sur les
quelques cas avérés n'ont pas mis en
évidence de risque pour la sûreté la
sûreté des transports de substances
radioactives s'est maintenue à un niveau
satisfaisant au regard du nombre
d'opérations effectuées et les résultats
obtenus en matière de radioprotection
dans le domaine industriel sont
acceptables même si une vigilance plus
forte encore être portée aux activités
de gammagraphie réalisés sur les
chantiers
enfin dans le domaine médical le nombre
d'événements significatifs de
radioprotection déclaré par les
professionnels de santé et demeurait
très faible en 2019 au regard du nombre
d'actes réalisés sur les patients et de
la complexité de certains de ces actes
derrière ces constats généraux qui vont
dans le bon sens
il faut souligner des nuances entre
exploitants nucléaires et entre
disciplines médicales et des points à
améliorer
chez edf tout d'abord malgré des
résultats de sûreté globalement
satisfaisant deux points de vigilance
sont apparus en 2019
la saturation des capacités d'ingénierie
et le recul de la rigueur d'exploitation
ces dernières années edf a engagé des
modifications ambitieuses de ses
installations dans le cadre des réexamen
périodique des réacteurs en 2019
edf a réalisé dans des conditions
satisfaisantes
la première quatrième visite décennale
d'un de ses réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
sur le site de tricastin
pour réussir cette opération edf a
mobilisé des moyens importants
d'ingénérie tant au niveau central qu'au
niveau du site pour concevoir ces
améliorations et accompagner leur
première mise en oeuvre sur le terrain
ce qui était indispensable mais l'asn
constate de plus en plus une saturation
des capacités d'ingénierie d'edf et
s'interroge sur sa capacité à mobiliser
de tels moyens à l'avenir sur les autres
réacteurs et donc à assurer avec succès
dans des plannings réalistes les
réexamens de sûreté par ailleurs revu
des constats qu'elle a effectués
l'asn considère que la rigueur
d'exploitation des centrales nucléaires
d'edf est en recul en 2019
trois constats peuvent illustrer cette
appréciation
tout d'abord trois nm3 événements
significatifs ont été classés au niveau
2 en 2019 sur le parc nucléaire d'edf
contre zéro en 2018 deux d'entre eux
mettent en évidence des gestes et des
décisions inadaptées des intervenants et
le franchissement de ligne de défense en
matière de sûreté comme par exemple sur
les sites de golfech
et de penly ensuite chaque année l'asn
réalise des mises en situation des
équipes d'edf
à l'occasion de ces inspections les
mises en situation réalisé en 2019 par
exemple la simulation d'un départ de feu
une inondation interne ou un rejet de
liquides dangereux ont démontré que la
documentation opérationnel d'edf
n'étaient pas toujours adaptés à la
réalité du terrain et qu'elle contenait
des erreurs voire d instruction
impossible à exécuter compte tenu de la
configuration des installations enfin si
edf a davantage privilégié la remise en
conformité rapide de son installation
après détection d'un écart l'année 2019
encore été marquée par la détection de
non-conformité résultant de la mise en
oeuvre deux modifications y compris
récemment ou d'une maintenance
insuffisante malgré des progrès
indéniables qu'il ya donc chez edf
un effort à faire pour renforcer la
rigueur d'exploitation qui fait appel à
la compétence et à la conscience
professionnelle des intervenants chez
aura nos cycles l'asn estime que le
niveau de sûreté des installations est
demeuré à un niveau satisfaisant en 2019
le groupe aura nos amis en place une
nouvelle organisation plus centralisée
mais s'appuyant sur les structures
dédiées sur site ce qui a permis
d'améliorer la qualité et des réexamen
périodique et de mieux maîtriser les
risques de vieillissement des
installations aura le cycle a achevé en
2019 la construction de la quasi
totalité des moyens complémentaires de
sûreté issus des évaluations réalisées à
l'itie ne l'accident de fukushima aura
nos cycles est en avance sur ce point
par rapport aux autres exploitants
nucléaires par exemple l'ensemble des
nouveaux moyens destinés à faire face à
des situations extrêmes comme de
nouveaux bâtiments de crise
robuste ou des moyens d'appoint d'eau
complémentaires ont été mises en place
deux points peuvent encore cependant
faire l'objet d'une vigilance de la part
de renault
tout d'abord la surveillance des
prestataires notamment ceux chargés des
contrôles et des essais périodiques
reste à améliorer et ensuite la maîtrise
des projets liés à la reprise des
déchets anciens et au démantèlement qui
connaissent des reports parfois pour des
dizaines d'années des échéances définies
par orane en 2019 l'asn a engagé avec
aura nos une démarche de contrôle de
gestion des projets avec l'appui de la
dgec qui sera poursuivie en 2020 puis
étendue progressivement aux autres
exploitants dans la même situation
enfin en ce qui concerne le cea l'asn
considère que la sûreté des
installations est restée globalement
satisfaisante en 2019
malgré un contexte budgétaire
préoccupant et les retards significatifs
dans la mise en oeuvre de certaines
mesures post fukushima
l'évolution de l'organisation mise en
oeuvre au second semestre 2010 9 sur le
chantier du réacteur jules horowitz
à karrada un quart d'heure âge pardon
est globalement satisfaisante mais les
enjeux principaux pour le cea porte sur
la poursuite de fonctionnement
d'installation conçu suivant des
standards de sûreté anciens aujourd'hui
largement dépassé ainsi que sur le
démantèlement des installations et la
gestion des déchets historiques près de
40 installations du domaine civil ou
militaire du ceva sont définitivement
arrêtées ou en démantèlement en 2019
l'asn et l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
de défense la snd ont examiné la
nouvelle stratégie de démantèlement
élaboré par le cea l'asn et la snd ont
confirmé la pertinence général un moyen
constant alloués par l'état de cette
stratégie et de la priorisation réalisés
notamment sur les sites de marcoule et
de saclay même si la réduction des
risques présentés par ses anciennes
installations ne sera pas effective
avant au mieux une dizaine d'années
l'asn et la snd on attirait l'attention
du premier ministre sur le fait qu'un
effort d'investissement spécifique et le
renforcement des équipes de sûreté dédié
à ces projets leur paraissait nécessaire
voilà les différentes appréciations pour
ce qui concerne les principaux
exploitants nucléaires hors
installations de stockage des déchets de
l'endroit qui ont dont le niveau de
sûreté est resté satisfaisant en 2019
les dernières nuance que je voudrais
souligner dans le bilan 2010 9 concerne
les disciplines médicales utilisant les
rayonnements ionisants en radiothérapie
les fondamentaux de la sécurité sont en
place et les démarches qualité progresse
en curiethérapie la sécurité des soins
la radioprotection des professionnels et
la gestion des sources scellées de haute
activité sont globalement satisfaisantes
en revanche dans le domaine des
pratiques interventionnelle radioguidés
l'asn estime que les mesures qu'elle
préconise depuis plusieurs années ne
sont toujours pas suffisamment prises en
compte pour améliorer la radioprotection
des patients et des professionnels
notamment pour les actes de chirurgie
réalisés dans les blocs opératoires des
écarts réglementaires sont fréquemment
relevées en inspection et des événements
sont régulièrement déclarés à l'asn en
raison de dépassements des limites de
dose délivrée chez les praticiens
interventionnelle l'état la
radioprotection est nettement meilleure
dans les services qu'ils utilisent cette
technique depuis longtemps par exemple
dans les services d'imagerie où sont
réalisées des activités de cardiologie
ou de neurologie interventionnelle des
progrès sont donc possibles pour la
scène la formation continue des
professionnels et l'intervention de
physiciens médicaux constitue
probablement les deux points clés pour
garantir la maîtrise des doses délivrées
lors des actes interventionnelle
j'aurai terminé la présentation de ce
rapport 2019 en soulignant trois faits
marquants de l'année écoulée
tout d'abord et comme vous l'avez
rappelé en 2019 l'asn a été amené à
prendre une décision lourde d'imposer la
réparation des soudures défectueuses sur
les traversées enceinte du circuit
secondaire
le père de flamanville l'asn a considéré
que la nature et le nombre
particulièrement importante des cars
survenue lors de la conception et de la
fabrication du circuit constitué un
obstacle majeur pour maintien en l'état
de ses soudures trois scénarios de
réparation des soudures ont été étudiés
par edf sur lesquels l'asn a fait part
de son analyse préliminaire des risques
et des points sensibles
en octobre 2019 edf a retenu en priorité
un scénario de réparation par
l'intérieur des traversées ce qui
nécessite le développement de moyens
particuliers d'intervention et ce qui
est en cours la qualification des
procédés est en cours avec une fin de
travaux de réparation envisagée à ce
stade par edf au second semestre
2021 et l'asn est en contact régulier
avec edf poursuite poursuivre par dont
l'élaboration de ces qualifications
par ailleurs au vu des investigations
supplémentaires
menés par edf à la demande de l'asn sur
l'ensemble des lignes vapeur et des
circuits d'alimentation en eau c'est une
centaine de soudure qui devront être
réparées avant la mise en service de le
prd soudure qui sont plus accessibles
que les soudures de traverser ans
un autre fait marquant de 2010 neuf
concernent la protection des centrales
nucléaires face aux risques naturels
l'année 2019 a été marquée par plusieurs
épisodes caniculaires et par le séisme
du teil survenu le 11 novembre 2019
en période de canicule et de sécheresse
les exploitants doivent veiller au bon
fonctionnement des systèmes de sûreté à
la capacité de refroidissement du
réacteur et à la maîtrise des rejets qui
peuvent être affectées par les
températures élevées de l'air ou de
l'eau ou par les débit trop faible dans
les cours d'eau lors des épisodes
caniculaires de 2019 l'asn a été amené à
l'edf pardon était ami a arrêté
plusieurs réacteurs et réduire la
puissance de certains autres l'asn n'a
pas relevé d'écart par rapport aux
consignes à respecter
néanmoins face à la répétition de ces
événements l'asn a demandé à edf de
définir un nouveau référentiel grand
chaud à prendre en compte lors des
réexamens de sûreté de tous les
réacteurs pour anticiper les effets du
réchauffement climatique
un autre événement 2019 est liée aux
risques naturels concerne le séisme le
niveau de séismes pris en compte dans la
démonstration de sûreté découle d'un
séisme historique relevé dans la zone
géographique dans laquelle se trouvent
les centrales nucléaires
mais ce niveau de séismes doit être
réévalué par edf périodiquement lors des
réexamens ou lors d'un événement nouveau
qui se produit dans l'intervalle c'est
ce qui s'est produit en 2019 avec le
séisme et du teil dans le niveau atteint
est apparu très proche du niveau
historique pris en compte dans la
démonstration de sûreté l'asn a demandé
à edf de déterminer si ce séisme devait
conduire à réévaluer le niveau de
séismes auquel les centrale nucléaire de
tricastin et de cruas de doit pouvoir
faire face cette analyse est en cours et
la sn prendra position sur ce sujet en
2020 le dernier fait marquant que je
souhaiterais évoqué concerne
l'élaboration du plan national de
gestion des matières et des déchets
radioactifs dont vous avez parlé
monsieur le président la préparation du
prochain plan a en effet fait l'objet
pour la première fois d'un débat public
préalable organisé en 2019 par la
commission nationale du débat public le
débat public s'est déroulée du 17 avril
au 25 septembre la commission nationale
du débat public et la commission
particulière du débat public ont
présenté les conclusions qu'elle tire de
ce débat le 25 novembre le ministre de
la transition écologique et solidaire et
l'asn ont communiqué le 21 février 2020
les suites qu'elle envisage de donner au
débat
je me limiterai en en citer quelques
unes pour illustrer les thèmes
prioritaires qui ont émergé des débats
tout d'abord une meilleure articulation
sera recherchée entre politique
énergétique et politique de gestion des
déchets et la gouvernance du plan sera
renforcée par exemple la périodicité
d'élaboration du pngmdr sera mise en
cohérence avec la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie ce qui n'est
pas le cas actuellement et
l'articulation du plan avec les
stratégies d'arrêt définitif et de
démantèlement des industriels sera mieux
explicités dans le plan pour répondre
aux attentes en matière de gouvernance
le fonctionnement de l'instance
d'élaboration et de suivi du plan sera
clarifiée et cette instance sera élargie
à des représentants des parlementaires
de la société civile et aux
représentants des collectivités locales
pour répondre aux besoins désormais
urgent le pngmdr prévoir à la mise en
oeuvre de nouvelles capacités
d'entreposage des combustibles usés en
tenant compte de l'avis rendu en 2019
par l'asn sur les options de sûreté du
projet de piscine d'entreposage
centralisée par présenté par edf
le plan prévoit en complément l'étude
des conditions et les situations dans
lesquelles un entreposage à sec des
combustibles usés pourrait être utile le
gouvernement fera évoluer le cadre
réglementaire applicable à la gestion
des déchets de très faible activité afin
d'introduire une nouvelle possibilité de
dérogation ciblées permettant une
valorisation au cas par cas des déchets
radioactifs métalliques de très faible
activité
après fusion et des contaminations le
pngmdr formulera des recommandations
quant aux modalités de mise en oeuvre de
telles dérogations en prenant en
considération les travaux menés à la
demande de l'opex par le haut comité
pour la transparence et l'information
sur la sécurité nucléaire
enfin le plan précisera les conditions
de mise en oeuvre de la réversibilité du
stockage des déchets à haute activité
vie longue
en particulier en matière de
récupérabilité des colis et poursuivra
la définition des modalités
d'association duplique aux étape
structurante du projet cigéo la
rédaction du 5ème plan et son évaluation
environnementale stratégique ées la
consultation du public
on prend lieu au début de l'année 2000
21 et le projet de plan sera ensuite
rendu publics et rentransmis alopexx